give me a number between one and twenty
nine oh that's that's annoying to count
I'm just gonna pick approximately 23
let's play jacks triolet Pro sounds like
a new name never play them before you
move provisionally rated okay let's play
E for just gonna play normal chess hmm
let's play very normal chess I'll play
this
hey I'm exchanging I wonder if this is a
exchange that Toyota Tongan was talking
about but now I have to remember what to
do in this position it's a common
mistake for beginners to take here and
then run into queen g4 I think I'm just
supposed to Castle I feel like I've only
I've only played the exchange Roy like
once or twice on me chess toilet not
again
with a thousand bits thanks toilet
noggin you're incentivizing needs to
play this opening more and more I think
t4 is a move
trying to remember I actually used to
play this I was like younger d4 is
usually the main idea like get rid of
this pawn get a little bit more space
I'm actually curious if he takes if I
can play e5 probably there's Bishop c5
there are cases where Bach plays at six
actually like taking an f6 to discourage
e5 Pavlovian Eric yeah if you give me
bits at certain juncture is you'll train
needs a to play certain openings
now there's two strategies in this
opening one strategy is to trade
everything and wind in the King pawn
ending because White has a the
unencrypted majority wait do I take with
Queen wait now I'm conflicted it's
taking with Queen looks really
attractive yeah let's take with Queen I
have to look up the theory afterwards I
just like the fact I'm attacking g7
maybe he'll play off six if he doesn't
play off six and he five is coming what
was I saying
oh yeah there's two strategies in this
opening first strategy is trading the
second strategy is just attacking in the
center because White's more developed
and White's castled but now it's a bit
more difficult it's a five doesn't quite
work I mean this looks really tempting
it's a battery and it's a pin
maybe I'm preparing e5 what is a meadow
hatre I don't know too many names of
traps
maybe I've seen it before I just don't
know that name there's ideas here of
just attacking the bishop like Bishop f4
bringing the knight c4 so I can't
complain
a4 e 5 rook a 300 or you sack the
exchange and then minor pieces are
better than rooks in the middle game
that would be interesting
yeah Bishop e7 was actually a move I was
hoping he wouldn't play cuz now I pretty
much have to trade Queens if I'm if I
move my queen off the D file I lose the
rook so do I take on da probably I play
Bishop f4 first and I'll probably go for
the strategy of trading which probably
makes toilet nog and happy and if he
takes on d4 probably take with Knights
then C sevens of targets you would have
to play like Bishop d8 or Bishop d6 but
then we can trade more
are there still issues with this dream I
think it's okay now I hope it's okay now
it's been green for a while
okay so yeah there's pretty much two
moves for luck
maybe there's three moves anybody's
Bishop here I probably don't want to
take unless I do want to take
decisions decisions okay he's just gonna
mean the facilitate more trades I'll
play Knights e to will trail off the
bishops in this case I all meesh the
rook so basically provoking him to take
on that four and it's gonna be a fun
situation like two nights four night in
Bishop Knights will usually coordinate
better and this bishops restricted like
you could play Bishop g4 with an f3
question here how do I want to develop
everything else if you're like a lot of
people would play Knight c3 well this
move makes no sense the Knights just
restricted now a 3-2 c4 is a possibility
I mean the knight is probably best on c5
Massey plays b6
I'm gonna start with a four this is
actually a very typical move in these
structures because if I can play a five
I try and clamp down on the queenside
and then maybe I bring the night to a
four and he'll probably complete
development somehow
oh also I have some ideas of rook a3
whoever was mentioning a for Brook a3 in
the chats I think you left some kind of
subliminal message for me to do this in
the game are those chest row fees behind
me yes yes actually
there's there's two bowling trophies up
there and one tennis trophy but the
majority are our chests row fees which I
want to get rid of I'm thinking of doing
like a giveaway where I just I hold a
tournament or I do some random like just
subscriber auction or just raffle
because they take up so much space I
just have to figure out like logistics
and shipping because some of them are
heavier okay so he castles King side if
I were black I would have played a5 I
would have tried to neutralize so now I
think a5 looks nice I'm in no rush and
be patient if he plays b6 I never take
just leave the pawn here
what's my best bowling game 253 I bowled
it when I was in like in seventh grade
it was such a good game wasn't such good
form I was getting so nervous towards
the end and it was like a part of a
series good three games serious I bowled
like 680 or something but I haven't gone
bowling in a while
it used to be my like my favorite thing
next to chess have I played farmville no
I don't play those stupid games on
Facebook that's not my thing
like g6 I mean I could capture a toilet
noggin would be happy if I trade more
but will I be happy I probably see he
gets up square for the bishop yeah let's
let's trade this will be an instructive
positional grind now I'm playing Knight
c3 with purpose because now I actually
have this maneuver and b6 is not so
preferable for him and if he plays
Bishop e6 and he's leaving himself with
two targets for when my knight does
reach c5
it's hard to stop my c5i finite c5 you
might have to drop back to see aids and
the great thing about this position when
it comes to like n game situations in
the exchange Roy is that it's very easy
for a white to make a pass pawn on the
Kings side because later it's just a
matter of playing like f45
and it's impossible for black to make a
pass pawn on the Queen side so people
play this opening kind of with this
long-term intention in mind I feel like
it's gonna work out nicely
it's kind of like being up upon I have
the Kings side majority and his Queen
side majority doesn't mean anything yeah
this was probably the best move let's
put the knight in place and then it's
still a matter of patience let's start
with f3 I just want to improve my King
I feel like white should have more
improving moves then black will have
improving moves and when I say improving
moves it's just about optimizing the
pieces maybe someday gaining space
putting a pawn in each for maybe g3 rook
d6 good move he wants to double up and
control the only open file I can't
really stop it I don't want to capture
so let's play King me too we might
actually trade like everything this is
gonna be funny
because if he plays here I'll play kini
too and then we'll get into a situation
where it's night versus Bishop I'm
expecting him to take twice on do you
want everything coming off the board I
mean he could leave the tension too if
he leaves attention I probably double up
myself
now there is a five second increment so
he shouldn't flag but he is getting low
on time okay this is gonna be
instructive I hope people are learning
stuff so the first goal is to bring the
king probably smack in the center this
bishops so restricted like the bishops
just tied down to this pond and he could
consider it be six
he's gonna put his came here
and then I'll put my king here if he
does play b6 I probably just drop back
and the pawns are a little bit weak
could even drop back here
I mean the question is where does the
night's ultimately want to go thinking
like d4 f4 which means it's the debate
between b3 or d3
let's do this I might very well end up
sacking upon on a five
we wants to play king c5
mmm interesting the bets man thanks for
the sub there's actually some
decision-making to to make especially
with this tension because this idea like
if my night moves and he plays us in
this it could be a bit irritating and he
wants to do this to chase away in the
nights so maybe just f4 I mean this is
kind of what I wanted to do anyway
and if he plays Bishop e6 I play 94 I
might even just want to trade off like
the knight for the bishop because the
King pawn ending should be winning also
having ideas now of c4 c5 give him
triple pawns
[Music]
well time is going to be a factor
okay c5 is played now c4 doesn't make
sense because son he plays this and this
so let's go for this I'm really never
scared if he takes if he pushes closes
things down my pawn is safe on a5
and there is immediate night see for
ideas
I was just calculating like a five
taking on you 594 King here doesn't work
so my night needs to find a happier
place
it's from synergy thanks for the bits
what do I do I don't know what to do
here that is thanks for the sub
I think I'll play King D 3 feels weird
it feels a bit weird to put the King on
a light square Ariel was takin things
for the Sun guys I have to focus on this
game so if you're gonna sub sub after
the game but I put the King on the light
square because I wanted to play e5 like
I wanted to make this work where if he
takes I play 94 he plays this and then I
play c4 wait that doesn't work at all
now because you've just played b5
so let's play Knight f3 now let's play
h3 Col move restricting Bishop g4 maybe
preparing before g4 he could play c4
I don't know how explosive it would be I
play king d4 do you play c5 like King
III is before and then I play C 3 like
eventually the the Queen side pawns will
just become locked up and then hold
flack
Ponzi for hmm yeah let's go for this he
has one idea of doing this and then
winning that pawn but I should be quick
enough on the kingside it could turn
into a race but that's okay I have my
running shoes so I think I should
probably start with c3
yeah I'm just gonna be patient he's kind
of stuck so why not gain more space g4
where do I play Knight f3
he wants a draw well but I don't want to
draw ya g4 let's start with this
the great thing about this position I
can kind of play on and try a bunch of
different ideas I'm gonna try the
non-committal ideas first which involves
like this move maybe if you play as g5 I
take and I went up on so that's
reasonable
maybe f5 hmm what the King on f3
maybe my knight can come here someday
or maybe I'll just go for like h4 and
then I'll all wind connect for I'll be
happy
I can just imagine him like suffering
right now is he's so long time like just
shaking with every move I play f5 here
goes away the square 95 is accessible
also 96 could be played
if this were a longer game I would just
calculate like trying to find the
winning idea but it still takes work
if you're feeling f5 should actually be
winning but it seems very criminal yeah
maybe my night does not want to be mine
I want to be I think that night wants to
be on each to it feels weird but it's
only square that defend the g4 and has
access to at three Belgium novice with a
Sun so no yeah let's start with this
because I want to play f5 and then I
want to play Knight f3 to chase the king
away and now we're going to get this
classic situation where okay well after
a few more trades of pawns
I'll more easily be able to make a
passer hopefully start with king f4
oh maybe I'll just play like g5g six and
then just push this pond okay so he
wants to break through your even better
I can play the stream just freeze again
what's going on with a stream okay it's
back I was gonna say even better I can
play g6 and then bring the knight to h5
oh but now it's a race wait a minute
g6 bishop g8i here came here here he
takes I take he takes I play here he
plays here right here he plays here I
play here way ahead okay
yeah this is gonna be a fun finish
wait till I calculate that correctly
here here here here yeah I did
well.all car that goes to toilet noggin
for inspiring me this beautiful opening
good game jockster the pro yeah that was
kind of a feel-good feel-good game I
don't know if I played like the most
accurately in this ending like it took
some work a lot of maneuvering but I
wanted to play a low risk chess I was
happy with 9h 2 because of the Knights
not in each to then g4 is not defended
so my King would have to stay here and
if I go for f5 so soon then King here
maybe it would still work where I would
still do this in this but anyway stumper
you know the newest sub gifted again by
toilet noggin